und wie angekündigt starten wir jetzt
live in den Deutschen Bundestag da ist
mein Kollege Gert Jochim von Follower
guten Morgen nach Berlin was erwartet
uns denn heute im Bundestag
ja heute morgen meine Damen und Herren
beschäftigt sich der Bundestag gleich
mit dem sogenannten doppelwumms so hat
der Bundeskanzler ja den 200 Milliarden
Euro Schirm zu Bekämpfung der
Energiekrise genannt und der wird heute
in erster Lesung quasi
gesetzgebungstechnisch auf den Weg
gebracht hier durch die Parlamentarier
es war ja schon überraschend dass die
gasumlage zwei Tage vor in Kraft treten
dann kassiert wurde oder wie der
Wirtschaftsminister Habig gesagt hat in
die Annalen der Geschichte eingegangen
ist statt eine Belastung der
Gasverbraucher hat der Bundeskanzler am
gleichen Tag verkündet es gäbe ein 200
Milliarden Paket mit einer
gaspreisbremse also einer Entlastung für
die Verbraucher und in diesem Paket
enthalten ist dann auch noch die Rettung
der gasimporteure die ja in schwere Not
geraten sind und eine
Zwischenfinanzierung soll dort enthalten
sein für die strompreisbremse die ja
auch noch nicht beschlossen worden ist
ja alles dieses muss man in Form bringen
und das tut man mit dem
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds der zum
Glück noch übrig geblieben war aus
corona-zeiten der soll jetzt ermächtigt
werden dieses Jahr 200 Milliarden Euro
noch aufzunehmen und in dieses Gesetz
muss dann auch noch rein wie dieses Geld
ausgegeben werden soll das ist ja noch
nicht so ganz klar es gab eine
Kommission die sehr schnell arbeiten
musste ein Zwischenbericht vorgelegt hat
96 Milliarden hat man da ausgerechnet
darauf kommen wir gleich nämlich im
Gespräch mit meinen Gästen die ich heute
morgen ganz herzlich begrüße Julia
Verlinden die stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzende der bündnisgrün ist
da nicht nur in Bonn wird heute
gearbeitet auch nach wie vor hier
morgens in Berlin natürlich guten Morgen
guten Morgen und Andreas Jung der
Energie- und klimapolitische Sprecher
der cdu/csu-fraktion und bekanntlich
stellvertretender Parteivorsitzender der
Christdemokraten
Frau Verlinden ich fahre gleich mal mit
der Tür ins Haus 200 Milliarden das ist
sehr sehr viel Geld aber reicht das denn
überhaupt wir gucken uns das mal an die
Rettung der energiebetreiber der der
gasimporteure 50 Milliarden das Paket
was viele sagen ist noch nicht so
ausgegoren was da vorgelegt wurde 96
Milliarden da fehlt noch eine Komponente
für den Mittelstand sagen viele da fehlt
vor allen Dingen für Öl und Pellet
Kunden etwas also das könnte auch noch
mehr werden und dann gibt es zum
Beispiel den Fraktionschef der SPD Herr
Mütze nicht der gesagt hat also einen
Monat in der Start im Dezember übernimmt
ist zu wenig ich könnte mir dann zweiten
Monat vorstellen ja reicht das denn aus
wenn das ganze geht bis zum Jahr 2024
und die Hoffnung dass die Gaspreise dann
deutlich wieder niedriger sein werden
woher nehmen sie die
also erstmal bin ich sehr dankbar dafür
dass die Regierung diese 200 Milliarden
jetzt zur Verfügung stellt weil wir
brauchen sie dringend für die Entlastung
und um gut durch diesen Winter zu kommen
sie haben recht es sind viele unbekannte
noch im Spiel auch dahingehend wie
entwickeln sich die Energiepreise auch
weiter in den nächsten Monaten aber wir
können jetzt klar sagen alle können sich
dann wenn das Ergebnis der Kommission so
umgesetzt wird auch tatsächlich auf
einen gedeckelten Gaspreis verlassen für
die nächsten Monate bis also mindestens
bis März 24 und ich glaube das ist ein
ganz wichtiges Signal im übrigen sind
alle gaskundinnen und Kunden davon
betroffen das heißt alle werden
entlastet auch der Mittelstand das heißt
alle profitieren sowohl von der
Einmalzahlung im Dezember als auch von
der dem gaspreisdeckel dann ab nächstem
Jahr insofern wird es mit Sicherheit den
ein oder anderen Härtefall geben auch
aber auch hierfür hat die Kommission
vorgeschlagen ein zusätzlichen hilfsfon
auf den Weg zu bringen und auszubauen ja
alle werden entlastet der Mittelstand
sagt jetzt schon das werden wir nicht
überleben wenn eine Zahlung im Dezember
kommt und die nächste dann im März oder
April durch den Deckel Herr Jungen die
Opposition kritisiert das ja unter
anderem auch und sagt es ist alles
nichts zielgenau das würde ja bedeuten
auch sagt die Opposition wir brauchen
eigentlich tatsächlich mehr Geld wo
wollen sie das her nehmen es ist gar
nicht klar ob wir mehr Geld brauchen
oder ob man auch so viel Geld braucht
weil die 200 Milliarden die haben sich
ja nicht aus irgendeiner seriösen
Rechnung ergeben mit dem man
festgestellt hätte wieviel brauchen wir
für die gaspreisbremse wie viel brauche
für die Unterstützung der Bürger wie
viel brauchen wir für den Mittelstand
sondern ist eine Hausnummer die einfach
in den Raum gestellt wurden um die
rhetorische Figur des doppelwurms
irgendwie zu unterlegen das ist die
Reihenfolge die wir kritisieren es geht
hier um viel Geld insgesamt geht der
Bundesfinanzminister mit 500 Milliarden
Euro Schulden in den Bundestag in diesem
Jahr und das sollte man nicht
leichtfertig tun es ist klar in dieser
Situation muss der Start stark reagieren
muss unterstützen und stützen aber dann
muss doch erstmal geklärt werden wie
viel brauchen wir wofür und das ist bis
zum heutigen Tag nicht getan worden wir
wissen bei der gaspreisbremse welche
Kosten die Kommission erwartet es gibt
noch keine Haltung der Bundesregierung
dazu bei den anderen Instrumenten haben
wir Lehrstellen die Reihenfolge ist
falsch und Christian Lindner muss
erklären wie das was er hier vorhat mit
den Vorgaben der Schuldenbremse des
Grundgesetzes zu vereinbaren ist weil
die Schuldenbremse sieht ja vor jedes
Jahr muss die eingehalten werden das
hier ist aber die Aktion Hamsterbacke
dieses Jahr werden viele Schulden
aufgenommen und schon jetzt ist klar das
Geld soll in den nächsten Jahren
verauslagt werden apropos Schuldenbremse
also die muss in diesem Jahr noch einmal
abgestimmt werden weil der 200
Milliarden dazu kommen das ist
wahrscheinlich nur pro forma da braucht
man die Kanzler mehr hat oder sehen Sie
da Schwierigkeiten ich sehe da überhaupt
keine Schwierigkeiten denn dafür ist ja
dieser dieser Posten im Haushalt
vorgesehen und ich glaube dass wir uns
alle einig sind dass wir hier wenn wir
entlasten wollen wenn wir gut durch
diesen Winter kommen wollen wenn wir die
Menschen unterstützen wollen bei diesen
stark steigenden Energiepreisen dann
müssen wir jetzt Geld ausgeben aber was
natürlich auch wichtig ist ist wir
müssen auch überlegen wie können wir
langfristig uns absichern vor steigenden
fossilen Preisen und deswegen ist es
auch gut jeder Euro der investiert wird
in erneuerbare Energien in
Energieeffizienz der hilft uns
langfristig und ist eine Versicherung
vor steigenden Energiepreisen ja das ist
ja die Diskussion auch auf dem grünen
Parteitag heute Abend die Frage eben die
AKWs die FDP will keine Verlängerung ich
will eine Verlängerung die Grünen
natürlich nicht das ist die
Angebotsseite die Opposition kritisiert
das ja auch und sagt jetzt muss Angebot
her auch unter anderem damit der Preis
sinkt ja es geht nicht um ein Ausstieg
aus dem Ausstieg wir haben mit guten
Gründen den Ausstieg aus der Kohle
verströmung beschlossen und den Ausstieg
aus der Kernenergie aber jetzt geht es
durch darum dass wir in dieser Krise
alle Kapazitäten nutzen um das was nach
wie vor droht auch nach Einschätzung der
Experten der Regierung nämlich ein
Notstand Blackouts dem entgegenzuwirken
das sagen ja die
übertragungs-szenario zu dem Ergebnis
des unter bestimmten Annahmen Blackouts
drohen das ist die Einschätzung der
Übertragungsnetzbetreiber im Stresstest
und deshalb haben wir eine ganz klare
Empfehlung ausgesprochen sie formulieren
uns dort es trinkt der Rad in dieser
Krise alle Kapazitäten nutzen und wir
erleben dass die Regierung auf
Braunkohle setzt die soll bis zwei 24
laufen aber ein CO2-neutrales Kraftwerk
im Emsland soll Ende dieses Jahres
abgestellt werden es soll ein
ölkraftwerk um Emsland zu ersetzen einem
angeworfen werden des CO2-Ausstoß das
passiert das passt nichts ist der Plan
der Bundesregierung ist uns in dieser
Woche in einer Antwort behauptet
Gestaltung
wie ist das mit dem AKW in Niedersachsen
das ist eines der modernsten überhaupt
1988 als Netz gegangen hat 11 Milliarden
Kilowattstunden
94%ige Auslastung es ist weltweit eines
der best ausgelastesten und sichersten
Atomkraftwerke und die Grünen sagen das
brauchen wir nicht mehr wie wollen Sie
diese 11 Milliarden Kilowattstunden
ersetzen wir brauchen das Atomkraftwerk
Emsland deswegen nicht weil wir im
Norden sehr sehr viel Strom produzieren
aus Erneuerbaren in der Vergangenheit
hat das Atomkraftwerk an dem Standort im
Emsland immer wieder auch dafür gesorgt
dass Windstrom abgeregelt werden musste
weil dieses Atomkraftwerk die Netze
verstopft hat also macht es überhaupt
gar keinen Sinn dieses Atomkraftwerk
auch nur einen Tag länger laufen zu
lassen als Silvester das ist das was
verabredet worden ist man Anstieg damals
übrigens mit Stimmen der CDU aber im
Norden wenn ich diesen Einwand machen
darf im Norden wird Braunkohle
angeworfen bis Ende 24 im Norden
Luftlinie 150 km von dem Kernkraftwerk
Emsland setzen sie auf Braunkohle die
Regierung hat uns mitgeteilt man stehe
in Verhandlungen über einen Standort für
das schwimmte ölkraftwerk auch im Norden
das alles so im Norden gibt
im Norden gemacht werden
nicht durch schwimmende ölkraftwerke
ersetzt werden müssen es gab Angebote
von privaten Unternehmen die der
Bundesregierung gesagt haben wir haben
diese schwimmenden Kraftwerke die
Stellen könnten wir zur Verfügung
stellen die Bundesregierung hat gesagt
brauchen wir nicht und das ist jetzt
eine privatwirtschaftliche Entscheidung
ob die einen Antrag stellen dafür müssen
natürlich Genehmigung erteilt wenn etc
aber mir ist kein solcher Antrag bekannt
wir brauchen diese schwimmenden
ölkraftwerke im Norden nicht wir haben
dort ausreichend Energie die
Bundesregierung hat uns etwas anderes
mitgeteilt aber ist ja leicht
aufzuklären sie antworte Staatssekretär
jung auffällig ist natürlich dass wenn
man mal ins europäische Ausland guckt
dort längst gaspreisbremsen Strompreis
Bremsen verabschiedet wurde gerade bei
strompreisbremsen in Österreich zum
Beispiel Zuge ich immer so ein bisschen
auf weil die deutsche Bundesregierung
sagt wir tun es da ganz schwer mit der
europäischen Komponente jetzt will man
das eben hier auch in diesen Fonds
reinpacken was ist da los eine
gaspreisbremse muss kommen das haben wir
es Union frühzeitig gefordert die
Kommission schlägt ist jetzt vor in den
Beratung ist deutlich geworden es
braucht ein Vorlauf von mindestens vier
Monaten dass unsere kernkritik hätte
Olaf Schulze es ja im Juli sein Satz
gesagt hat Jul never walk alone keiner
wird alleine gelassen hätte er dort
statt der gasumlage die ja Preise erhöht
hätte gleich auf preisdämpfung gesetzt
gleich die Kommission eingesetzt dann
hätten wir diese Bremse jetzt im Winter
und die brauchen wir jetzt im Winter
weil die Bürger und die Betriebe jetzt
hart betroffen sind so soll die Preis
erst wenn es gut geht im März vielleicht
im April kommen und als Brücke so nennt
ist die Kommission so ist eine
Einmalzahlung geben die wirft aber sehr
viele Fragen auf und die wird bestimmt
nicht alle Existenzfragen lösen können
und deshalb ist es falsch dass die
Bundesregierung am Mittwoch angekündigt
hat dass es
betriebshilfeprogramm also das
energiekostenprogramm mit dem Zuschüsse
für Unternehmen gewährt werden die in
Existenznot sind das ist eingestellt
werden sollen nicht alle Existenzfragen
werden durch diese Bremse gelöst werden
und deshalb kritisieren wir dass hier
der Mittelstand alleine gelassen wird
Vorfall Linde Expertenkommission hat
auch gesagt wir arbeiten hier natürlich
ein riesen Geschwindigkeit man wartet
jetzt noch auf das Endergebnis in drei
Wochen auf die Steuerschätzung wie
schnell geht denn die deutsche
Gesetzgebung denn das was die
Expertenkommission vorgelegt hat ist ja
nur ein Kompromiss dessen man hätte das
viel schöner gestalten können wenn man
diese dusselige gasumlage früher
abgeschafft hätte also ich glaube wir
haben jetzt in den letzten Monaten als
Ampelkoalition ge zeigt wie schnell wir
in dieser Krise Entscheidungen treffen
können weil das notwendig ist wir haben
sehr viele parlamentarische Prozesse
beschleunigt an dieser Stelle nochmal
herzlichen Dank an die Union die als
Opposition auch in zahlreichen
Gesprächen auch zugestimmt hat dass wir
zum Beispiel diese Prozesse
beschleunigen weil das natürlich
notwendig ist dass wir in dieser
Krisensituation schnell handeln können
ich möchte nur noch mal kurz darauf
hinweisen dass wir zahlreiche Maßnahmen
bereits beschlossen haben und auch schon
Geld bei den Menschen angekommen ist
also zig Milliarden Euro sind ja schon
in den letzten Monaten auch
Heizkostenzuschuss einmal verbinden wenn
ich sie unterbrechen darf dank an die
Opposition die Opposition hat ja schon
früher mehreren Monaten so eine
gaspreisbremse vorgelegt ich glaube 75
Prozent sollen gedeckelt werden bei 12
Cent und jetzt sind es 80 Prozent laut
Kommission bei 12 sind das hätte man
doch Monate früher haben können und
müssen also die größten
gaspreissteigerungen die stehen sehr
vielen Kunden noch bevor also es stimmt
es gibt Menschen die haben bereits jetzt
einen deutliche Erhöhung ihres Abschlags
per Brief bekommen von ihrem Versorger
aber die noch viel größeren Steigerung
die werden ja in den nächsten Monaten
erst verschickt und deswegen glaube ich
dass es gut ist dass diese Kommission
sehr schnell gearbeitet hat ich bin
allen Mitgliedern sehr sehr dankbar und
ich möchte nur noch mal darauf hinweisen
diejenigen die zum Beispiel Wohngeld
bekommen haben bereits ein
Heizkostenzuschuss auf Ihr Konto
erhalten und das betrifft dann eben auch
alle egal ob sie Gas Öl oder mit anderen
heizstoffen eben ihre Wohnung warm
bekommen also an der Kommission liegt
nicht Deutschland die zurück das haben
wir jetzt klar festgestellt jetzt muss
man damit umgehen aber der Mittelstand
die kleinen Betriebe das Handwerk sagt
das wird nichts mit der Einmalzahlung da
im Dezember wir müssen Januar Februar
überbrücken gerade zum Beispiel die
Bäcker die berühmten Bäcker die auch
viel mit Strom Arbeiten sagen bis dahin
gibt es uns einfach nicht mehr die
brauchen jetzt Unterstützung deshalb ist
es falsch das Programm einzustellen
Robert habe Katja angekündigt ist zu
öffnen für den Mittelstand gerade für
Bäckereien zu öffnen stattdessen soll es
jetzt eingestellt werden das ist die
falsche Weg und es gibt zum Beispiel
Bäckereien die haben mit staatliche
Unterstützung umgestellt auf Pellets und
da haben wir auch Preissteigerungen von
dem doppelten und dreifachen und der
soll gar nichts gemacht werden deshalb
brauchen wir da antworten und es reicht
nicht wenn wir etwas tun nur für
Wohngeld das ist richtig aber es gibt
Menschen die etwas mehr verdienen und
trotzdem hat betroffen der Junge hat ja
recht hatten wir die
energiepreispauschale Herr Jung hat
recht da soll nichts gemacht werden bei
Öl und Pellets aber ja nur nach dem
Kommissionsentwurf wenn ich jetzt die
SPD zum Beispiel höre das ist ja nicht
das Gesetz was hier der Bundestag
verabschieden wird wird der Gesetzgeber
da also für diese Menschen noch
nachlegen wir gucken uns das sehr genau
an wir werden das parlamentarisch prüfen
die Regierung prüft ja auch gerade was
ist davon wie umsetzbar natürlich muss
man da verschiedene administrative
Rahmenbedingungen beachten und diese
Diskussion wird dann hier im Parlament
laufen vielen Dank dass sie da waren es
geht nämlich jetzt los im Deutschen
Bundestag also 200 Milliarden Euro
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsform muss
ermächtigt werden und ich gebe rein